One of the things that Vladimir Putin is doing
right now that is just like total villain
dictator vibes is he's making a list. It is a
list of all of the people that he deems foreign
agents. A foreign agent used to be any person who
received money from other countries. Then after
the war started, he changed the foreign agent
list to be anyone who receives “influence” from
other countries, which like, how do you define
influence? However you want. This list is now just
a list of anyone that Putin doesn't like. These
people now have to disclose that they are foreign
agents at the front of all of their videos, on all
of their tweets... On anything that they do, they
have to say, “I am a foreign agent.” It's a great
way to stigmatize yourself from getting ad revenue
or doing anything in Russia. And it's a great way
for Vladimir Putin to silence his critics. Russia
is becoming a fascist state, and that is very sad
for the people living there. I talked to a bunch
of them, dozens of them, in fact, for a story
that we did on YouTubers in Russia, journalists
in Russia. It’s an incredible story told by these
voices. It’s over on my YouTube channel. K, bye.